[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean tissé un projet dont le concept a
débuté il ya une dizaine d'années
maintenant puisque en fait la première
brique technologique qui était
nécessaire c'est le développement d'un
modèle animal capable de reproduire de
façon fidèle la maladie d'alzheimer et
ça c'est une étape qui a été réalisée
pendant que j'étais chercheurs
académiques au civa de
fontenay-aux-roses la problématique avec
la maladie d'alzheimer c'est que il ya
deux éléments à rectifier si on veut
soigner les patients un jour c'est un
diagnostic et des patients plus tôt donc
il ya un stade où le cerveau est encore
suffisamment répond de retraitement pour
pour être soigné et le deuxième problème
c'est que les modèles animaux qu'on
utilisait pour identifier les
modulations sanguine n'était pas
suffisamment proche donne donc la
première étape a consisté à la
développer un modèle animal suffisamment
proche de l'homme la deuxième étape a
été d'identifier sur cet animal les eaux
du lac ution sanguine qu'il est pouvoir
servir de signature de la maladie
alzheimer est la dernière étape a été de
montrer que ce qui était observé chez
l'animal était aussi utilisable chez
l'homme pour diagnostiquer les patients
donc là l'idée a émergé l'idée de créer
une start up et donc j'ai tout de suite
cherché un associé qui finalement l'être
non content mais non scientifique
business purement business et dans ce
cadre là j'ai rencontré baptiste et donc
moi j'ai une formation purement business
j'étais le maire de la chaussée en 2015
et je cherchais un projet dans lequel un
vestiaire et un projet qui avait du sens
donc quand jérôme a parlé de ce projet
d'alzheimer j'ai tout de suite je me
suis tout de suite dit que c'était ce
projet la kiné qui fait dans lequel il
fallait que je passe le plus peur de
mourir tout notre approche consiste
finalement à générer de la date à partir
des modulations sanguine qu'on avait
près identifiée chez l'animal est donc à
calibrer des algorithmes mathématiques
et des algorithmes d'intelligence
artificielle pour pouvoir utiliser les
marqueurs sanguins pour diagnostiquer
les patients et ça de façon très très
précoce on a fast trade est prêt
démentiel voir dans une phase où le
patient ne présente absolument aucun
symptôme de maladie d'alzheimer ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que d'un point de vue
traitement on a fait énormément
d'avancées dans les cinq dernières
années et on espère que d'ici à deux
trois ou quatre ans on va avoir des
médicaments qui ont être efficace pour
ralentir la progression de la maladie
est potentiellement un médicament pour
être en mission marché d'ici à six mois
aux etats unis et là il va se poser une
problématique un paradis un paradoxe
parents historique
par rapport à la maladie d'alzheimer
c'est à dire qu'en dehors des
traitements mais on sera dans
l'incapacité de pour le prescrit au plus
grand nombre
faute de diagnostic facilement
applicable à une grande population est
donc là le diagnostic et jean thie
pourrait finalement servir de chaînon
manquant entre ces thérapeutiques
efficaces et la possibilité de prescrire
au maximum de gens pour ralentir de
façon massive la progression de la
maladie d'alzheimer
[Musique]